you know what I love when guys tell me
this oh my god the most pathetic line
ever
you're ready but you don't understand
that you know I'm like a nympho and so
my desire for sex is more than yours but
what do you think you've owned like this
sexual desire thing like you think
you're the only one that goes oh my gosh
you just focus focus focus
go go go she's gone okay perfect
safe we're safe awesome we're in the
same place right you think you're the
only one like what do you think
you don't think pastors one time I does
that's the question
oh hey I mean you know you're pretty
good-looking guy I said we're just this
guy going with this aside how you doing
with all these honey's that kind of like
here at this church man you know I seen
some big girls look at you it's added
ain't easy look at that statement we had
it ain't easy but I'm a leader perfect
dance that's on you to tell me
so you tell me what do you think he
cycles 40 freakin miles every time you
say you don't be like something happens
that at that saw some level like you
understand like I know I'm coming home
be ready tonight because it's like
upcoming okay tell the kids to go to
freakin they don't take a girlfriend out
shut the door take the dogs out go
upstairs I'm coming home praise the Lord
whatever kind of music a tussle do you
know mercy me or whatever they listen I
don't know what pastors have sex do you
ever think about that like they got
y'all other thinks about I mean I like
Arnon people that have them but have sex
too it's popcorn if you have sex of
Christian music what any weird
have you thought about that like babe
let's put some Christian easy I couldn't
do it I can't do it babe
change it up my you only guy that thinks
about these things or really anything
some okay almost given last you ain't
the only one man oh my gosh she get over
it
seventy two year olds still get excited
nowadays with the amount of Technology
freaking dead people get excited
does that make movement right there a
little bit did you see what happened
are they water the plants I sweated this
what are you put in those plants I saw
some blue pills they were drop anything
I don't know what's going on but
definitely definitely live it
man that's excited you think you're the
only one that's so proud of getting
excited like my son he's so proud and he
goes so proud he is so proud man so
we're done
what are you doing look daddy look at
this thing daddy's Holyoake Bob you wish
go show Tumelo bug to everyone like bro
can you freakin room a bunch of bats
them did this kid was 13 months old
already getting some at 13 months early
like you think you own this thing get
over it just control its control its
control its control believe me it ain't
easy I'm telling you on the road I have
to have systems for I've told some of
you about the systems but after I don't
want them others in
was sitting in front when I told them
the system and they're trying to hold
their face were you there - I think
they're - they're like that really just
said that I said be ready to say that as
you just keep that system back your mind
somewhere and it was the most Awkward
walk away from a conversation with your
CEO like those guys approve probably
mentally screwed for the rest of their
lives
okay but I guarantee they're going to
tell that story to other people I don't
care if they haven't already I give them
a lot of people and they